Here is something I want to address that has
come up quite a bit because of what we're
experiencing right now since the killing of
George Floyd by Derek Schavan.
There are people on the left and on the right
who will sometimes try to tout their nonracist,
bona fide days by using some version of the
phrase, I don't see color.
Now, different people will use that phrase
to mean different things.
There are people who will sometimes use the
phrase, I don't see color when they're called
out about some policy that will, like, disproportionately
affect minorities.
They'll say, I don't see color.
I'm just talking about policy.
Sometimes you will see people say, I don't
see color in the sense that they say they
are color blind in their political views.
This is a very dumb phrase, and I would suggest
that it not be used anymore.
And I want to be clear that I understand what
people often mean when they say, I don't see
color and I'm going to give you a better way
to talk about it, that that's more credible
because I don't see color doesn't really make
any sense, because all of the science tells
us we very much see color.
We just do.
Doesn't mean we're racist.
That doesn't mean we discriminate.
But the instant that we meet people, whether
it's Western individuals in developed countries
or remote tribes in the Amazon or the Australian
outback, we almost instantly are assessing
and assimilating what we believe to be the
gender of the person we are talking to, the
age of the person we are talking to.
And the race of the person we are talking
to.
To the extent that you can discern that from
looking at them.
The instant I walk up to a cashier at my grocery
store, I am instantly making an assessment
of I'm speaking to a roughly 30 year old Hispanic
female, for example.
We all see color and we all are instantly
assessing it because it's just part of being
human and living in a society.
Is there any situation in which someone could
come up to you and say, hey, remember the
gardener that came to the house last week?
Do you remember if they were male or female?
No, I have no recollection of it.
Of course you do.
Was the nurse that did your Kovik test.
Was it like a 20 something nurse or was it
like a 60 something year old nurse?
I have no I don't remember.
Was your bank teller yesterday white, black,
Asian or Hispanic?
I have no idea.
We all know it unless, you know, barring some
kind of memory or cognitive issue.
So when I hear people say things like I don't
see color in my interactions with the world,
people are just people.
Give me a break.
You do.
You see gender and you see age.
And we are immediately assessing race and
color as well.
We all see each other.
We recognize how someone might look similar
or different from us.
And that is OK.
What might actually be accurate to say and
where I think the focus should be is I don't
judge people on the basis of their appearance,
which includes race.
That might be accurate.
Now, a lot of us still have implicit and preconceived
notions about people on the basis of these
characteristics.
In many cases, they're relatively benign,
and that's fine.
Sometimes they are discriminatory.
But I actually want to go even further imagined
that it were true.
We don't notice people's race.
We really don't see color.
When.
If.
Were to be the case.
It would immediately dismiss the reality that
there are racial injustices even today in
society.
If I didn't see color.
If someone said to me, hey, can you snap your
fingers?
And you could you could snap your fingers
and become black right now and society, would
you want to do it?
If I didn't see color, I'd have no way to
answer that question.
Now, of course, I see color.
And of course, I recognize that I would likely
be worse off in society if I were black than
being white, Hispanic as I am and passing
as white.
I see color and that allows me to recognize
that if someone says you could snap a finger
and be black, do you want to do it?
No, I'd be worse off in society if I did that.
I recognized that in part because I see color.
We also all see color, by the way, by virtue
of seeing how different people are treated
in society by different institutions.
And we're, of course, seeing that very much
with the George Floyd situation.
So I think that that just about covers it.
I find the phrase I don't see color to be
to be pretty silly, quite frankly.
And for people who are trying to make the
case that they're not making judgments about
others on the basis of race that I like.
It may be true.
It may not be true.
It's certainly something to aspire to.
But let's be more accurate when we talk about
it.